- Pain.
- You embrace the pain.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all
of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
how you can embrace the pain.
And also, guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it, and
you might win a prize,
but also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat music)
- Pain is temporary.
It may last for a minute, or an hour,
or a day, or even a year.
But eventually it will subside.
And something else will take its place.
If I quit, however, it will last forever.
Listen to me, I'm telling
you all as I leave.
I'm telling you as I leave,
I was homeless for two and a half years.
And the problem with most of you,
you never felt no pain before.
You all spoiled.
Some of you all spoiled, just bottom line.
Your parents have done everything for you.
You never had to do nothing for yourself.
You're spoiled.
We going to keep it real tonight.
Some of you are spoiled brats.
Every time you ever got in trouble
somebody in your house got you out of it.
Every time you done something
you're not supposed to do
people say, Eric's your mother's a tyrant.
You're right, she kicked me out.
You're right, she's mean.
But she developed a man,
because she put me out there and said,
you're going to have to grow up.
And some of you have
never learned to grow up.
And so every time something
get hard, you quit,
you call momma.
I dare you to take a little pain.
I dare you.
I dare you not to go home.
Somebody say, if I don't
go home I feel bad.
Go through it.
You ain't going to die.
At the end of pain is success.
You're not going to die cause
you're feelin' a little pain.
I'm not eating like I eat at home.
That's why you're about
to go to the next level,
cause if you keep eating
like you eat at home,
you will keep being a boy, or a girl.
It's time to become a man, woman.
So don't worry about a little pain.
- Pain...
Is necessary.
It's inescapable.
There's no way,
I mean out of pain, we are born.
Pain is a must.
Pain is a necessity of growth.
Be comfortable with being uncomfortable.
Pain is a necessary evil.
Get used to it.
Make friends with it,
and kick (bleeping) pain's ass.
And that way, when it comes
to take you down, you can brush
that (bleeping) (bleep) off.
I'm used to you, (bleep),
come on bring it on.
Sit your ass down
and let's have a
(bleeping) lunch together.
You and me, pain, let's do it.
Let's (bleeping) bring it.
- There's a bunch of people that will say,
well, I have a family,
so it's all a great idea
for you to just go out there and go crazy,
I have people to support.
You need to listen.
Stop saying that.
Stop saying any of those things.
Any single person who has
ever done anything worthwhile
or exceptional or
difficult or extraordinary,
anyone, whether it's
great artists or authors
or mathematicians or
whatever the (bleep) it is.
Everyone encounters difficulties.
There is no easy road.
It does not exist, it is impossible.
Everyone has issues.
If you have time to pursue a hobby,
if you have time to do
anything in your life,
you can better yourself.
And here's one way you
never better yourself:
when you come up with excuses for why
other people are
successful, and you're not.
That (bleep) is (bleeping) dangerous.
When you give yourself an escape.
Yeah, well that's easy for you to say,
You know, you do this...
Trust me.
Everybody has a hard road.
I wanted to jump out
a window several times
during my young life.
I wanted to jump in front
of a (bleeping) train,
just end it because
it's too much pressure.
Not really.
But you know what I'm
saying, theoretically.
We all go through hard times,
we all go through depression,
we all go through doubt
and moments in your life
when it's really (bleeping) difficult
and you're trying to
figure out what the (bleep)
your path is going to be.
It's hard as (bleep).
But Steph and I were talking about this
before this podcast starts,
that that is what makes you a person.
And those difficult moments
are what build your character
Show me a great man who's
the son of a great man,
that's what we're saying.
You know, these kids that were
born billionaires, you're (bleeped).
You're (bleeped).
You're never going to
be a self-made person.
You have a back-up trust
for your back-up trust
for your trust, and you're (bleeped), man.
- By experiencing pain in your muscles
and aching, then go on
and go on and go on,
and those last two or
three or four repetitions,
that's what makes actually
the muscle then grow.
And that divides one
from being a champion,
and one from not being a champion.
If you can go through this pain period,
you may get to be a champion.
If you can't get through, forget it.
And that's what most people lack,
is having the guts.
The guts to go in, and go through,
and say, I don't care what happens.
It aches, and if I fall down...
I have no fear of fainting in a gym,
because I know it could happen,
I threw up many times
while I was working out,
but it doesn't matter.
Because it's all worth it.
- I wasn't happy,
focused on the short term money coming in
when creating a company,
because otherwise the company will die.
So the...
A lot of times people think,
creating a company is going to be fun.
It's really not that fun.
I mean, there are periods of fun.
And there are periods
where it's just awful.
And particularly, if you're
the CEO of a company,
you actually a have distillation
of all the worst problems
in the company.
There's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right,
so you're only spending
your time on things
that are going wrong.
And there are things that are going wrong
that other people can't take care of.
So you're the worst...
You have a filter for
the crappiest problem
in the company.
The most pernicious and painful problem.
I wouldn't say it's...
I think you have to feel
quite compelled to do it,
and have a fairly high pain threshold.
And there's a friend of mine who says,
starting a company is like
staring into the abyss,
and eating glass.
And there's some truth to that.
The staring into the abyss part
is that you're going
to be constantly facing
the extermination of the company.
Because most start-ups fail.
It's like 90%, 99% of start-ups fail.
So that's the staring into the abyss part,
you're constantly saying, okay,
if I don't get this right,
the company will die.
Which can be quite stressful.
And then, the eating glass part is,
is you got to work on the problems
the company needs you to work on,
not the problems you want to work on.
And so that's...
You're going to wind
up working on problems
you really wish you weren't working on.
And so that's the eating glass part.
And so that goes on for a long time
- [Audience Member] So
how do you keep your focus
on the big picture when
you're constantly faced with,
we could be out of business in a month.
- Well, it's just a very small
percentage of mental energy
is on the bigger picture.
You know where you're
generally headed for,
and the actual path is going to be
some sort of zig-zaggy
thing in that direction.
You try not to deviate
too far from the path
that you want to be on.
But you're going to have
to do that to some degree.
I don't want to diminish the...
The profit motive is a good one,
if the rules of an industry
are properly set up.
So there's nothing
fundamentally wrong with profit.
In fact, profit just means
that people are paying you more
for whatever you're doing,
than you're spending to create.
That's a good thing.
And if that's not the case,
then you'll be out of
business and rightfully so.
You're not adding enough value.
- The key is what we do
in our times of pain.
Pain will change us.
Heartache, loss, disappointment,
they don't leave us the same.
When I lost my father,
I didn't come out like I was before.
I was changed.
If you go through a
divorce, a legal battle,
a friend betrays you,
eventually that will pass.
You'll get through it,
but you'll be different.
No how the pain changes you, is up to you.
You can come out bitter,
or you can come out better.
You can come out with a chip
on your shoulder, blaming God,
or you can come out stronger,
with a greater confidence in God.
You can come out defeated,
giving up on your dreams,
or you can come out with
a new passion, a new fire,
excited about the new
opportunities in front of you.
All of us experience pain.
My challenge: don't just go
through it, grow through it.
That difficulty is an
opportunity to get stronger,
to develop character,
to gain new confidence.
Anybody can give up,
anybody can let it overwhelm you.
But you know what that's doing?
Wasting your pain.
That pain is not there to stop you,
it's there to prepare you,
to increase you, to develop you.
- People used to take my
raps and crunch them up,
and throw them on the ground.
I used to get make fun of all the time,
cause who believes that
the guy sitting next
to them in math class is going
to blow up and become a superstar?
Right, you don't believe that.
But like, you should have.
And it's a bummer, you what I mean?
Take it and make...
You know, pain is the best inspiration.
So if you're a creative out there
and you're getting bullied,
take it and make
something great out of it.
- Have you ever watched
the James Bond movie
where it doesn't look like
he's losing at some point,
and then he wins?
Or Batman?
Or Iron Man?
Or any superhero?
There has to be some diversity
for to overcome, to win.
You can't be a champ unless you
are in a place where you look
like you're going to lose,
and then you win.
The pain's that going to
come with being independent,
you have to embrace it.
Because it's going to happen.
And also know that the
more successful you get,
the more problems you're going to have,
the more knots you're
going to have to untie.
Being a boss does not mean smooth sailing,
it means having the ability
to care about other
people before yourself,
and to untie problems, untie knots.
That's all it is.
It's not business if there's not problems.
There's nothing good without struggle.
It just doesn't happen.
In all my experiences,
there hasn't been one thing
that's been successful without me
feeling some pain before
it was successful.
So now when there is pain, I embrace it.
I've been embracing it, I'm a G about it
because I know that must mean,
that if I'm cool, then, what awaits me...
It's darkest before the dawn.
I don't want to sound corny,
but that's what has to happen.
- And I know that I personally
that I personally have experienced
quite a bit of disappointment in my life.
And I'm assuming that you have as well.
And guess what?
We're going to continue to be disappointed
throughout our lives.
At least we should be.
Cause if you're not,
that means that you're really not trying.
Now how you handle yourself
post-disappointment,
this is critical to your
emotional and mental well-being.
Pain.
Hurtin'.
Right?
It's part of the growing process.
But I'll tell you something:
life has a funny way of closing doors
in order to keep you moving
in the right direction.
So often in our society and as people,
we run from pain.
We do everything we can
to protect ourselves
and to shield ourselves
from feeling uncomfortable,
that feeling of pain.
And this is the reason why so many people
abuse drugs, alcohol, casual sex.
We do this to not feel the pain,
but I'm saying, stop running.
Stop trying to mask it.
When you feel pain,
disappointment, it's okay.
Don't try and cover it up.
What you should do is actually embrace it.
I know, it's easy for me sitting here,
saying, oh, embrace the pain.
You're feeling like crap,
don't worry about it.
Feel it.
I get it, right, that's not...
That's kind of a long shot.
But what I'm saying, is
that the pain is normal,
it's natural, it's a part
of the growth process.
Learn from it.
Once you do, you accept
it, you embrace it,
learn from it, put it in its place,
you're going to be able to move forward,
faster, stronger, smarter.
If you're not struggling
and getting disappointed
from time to time, this probably means
that you're not really
pushing your limits too far.
All right, it's okay.
Embrace it, don't get
discouraged, and stay focused.
- Pain is a beautiful thing.
Challenge is what life is about.
A life without challenge,
a life without pain,
is a life without growth.
And where is there no growth,
there is stale, stagnant energy.
And that's where most people live.
Cause most people's
lives are designed around
treading a path that is void of challenge.
The minute they recognize
challenge or pain,
they move away.
This is a primal instinct,
and normal and natural.
But a weak perspective.
Most people are bored, if you ask them.
What do you think about your life.
(sigh)
Same old, same old.
Every single day, what's the thing...
Same (bleep), different day.
Things of this nature.
That's because they're
living their lives...
in a lie...
That is shrouded in comfort.
It doesn't exist.
They're not challenged,
they're not growing.
They're bored, and
they're better off dead.
Your aliveness is found in your pain.
Embrace it, love it, and grow from it.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know, what did
you take from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life, to your business.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really excited to
see what you have to say.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.